this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 53 sitting here with Echo Charles
EC already having a rough morning over
there on your side
doing great been a rough morning you've
been here for seven minutes it hasn't
been Pleasant for you
I'm doing the best thing okay
so you're still keeping a positive
attitude it's interesting that
the way the world works right everybody
everybody's allegedly different right
everyone's a different person
and yet there's all these categories
that you can put people in yeah
and somebody asked me about this the
other day the whole introvert extrovert
thing it's a thing right which is
interesting that you can say that these
radically different individualistic
human beings they all can be put in
these categories so
introvert
is a person and this is from
webmd.com I'm citing my sources sure
yeah
the introvert is a person with
equalities of a personality type known
as introversion which means they feel
more comfortable focusing on their inner
thoughts and ideas rather than what's
happening externally they enjoy spending
time with just one or two people rather
than large groups or crowds they have a
list of things here need quiet to
concentrate are reflective are
self-aware take time making decisions
feel comfortable being alone don't like
group work prefer to write rather than
talk feel tired after being in a crowd
have few friendships but are very close
with these friends Daydream or use their
imaginations to work out a problem
Retreat into their own mind to rest
where are you at you is that you that's
well the main two that I heard as far as
the differentiated between introvert
extra actually because they did hear one
hand where it's like oh yeah it's not
real or whatever and then wait what's
not real
introvert versus extrovert but I didn't
I put it so I didn't like I wasn't like
convinced put it that way I thought I
thought there really seems like there is
such thing as introvert because you know
you can just think of your friend well
there's somebody and we're gonna get to
we're gonna get to two more one's an
Omniverse and one's an ambivert we're
gonna get to that in a second yeah so
the other never heard of facets rolling
in here yeah but the ones the the two
defining characteristic whatever for
introvert and it's going to be opposite
for extrovert is the feel tired after
being in a crowd is that you oh me um
wait why are you signaling that one out
because that's what I heard as far as
the actual definition it has to do with
like people you know like you can be an
introvert and still do well with crowds
and talk good and you know like all the
stuff in public speaking it's draining
it takes energy and then other people
but extrovert apparently from what I
heard is they feel they're the opposite
when they're alone they get like
this is like too much to be alone I
gotta get out and have like people
interaction I'm real weird because I
don't care I'll be alone and not care
but be totally stoked whatever sitting
there playing guitar writing a book uh
just doing anything alone and I'm fine
don't care yes you are weird or I can be
with people hanging out and I'm fine I'm
not it doesn't uh use energy
or anything like that no look you take
that to the extreme sometimes you can be
like all right I I guess maybe this
leads me towards introvert a little bit
but you take it to an extreme where you
got a thing and there's a bunch of
people yeah
then you really don't want to be around
a bunch of people so I guess that's a
little bit of it makes me a little bit
of a
of an introvert a little bit more but I
don't actually but I actually don't care
yeah well I guess I don't know I mean if
this is like a technical thing actually
as I'm reading this I'm okay let me go
extrovert yeah wait what's the technical
thing because I cut you off not well the
as far as a technical thing like if it's
you know how like you can be like
you know you can be in condition for
certain things like oh I mean I'm kind
of in shape for this therefore it's not
a factor running a marathon is not a
factor for me but let's face it I'd
rather do Sprints or something like this
or whatever so you might be kind of like
that where you can endure a lot of
extrovert activity but
at the end of the day your your actual
introvert you're just in shape for the
extrovert yeah that might be right uh
extrovert here's a personality trait
typically characterized by outgoing as
high energy or talkativeness in general
like it's so funny because I literally
talk for a living
and if you if you you know if my wife
and I go to a party where I don't know
people I'm not saying anything to
anybody we're not talking to anybody or
she can yeah but I'm like hi
[Laughter]
so it says in general the term refers to
say to being where someone recharges or
draws energy from being with other
people
um here's here's some some highlights
you enjoy social settings you don't like
or need a lot of alone time you thrive
around people you're friends with many
people you prefer to talk out problems
or questions you're outgoing in
optimistics you aren't afraid to take
risk and you're flexible that's from
Psychology today by the way those two
definitions
so the weird thing for me is I am super
flexible yeah and I don't and I take
risks with almost I take risk very
easily I have no problem taking risks
uh I do talk through problems but I
actually I actually usually think
through problems and I let other people
talk about them and I kind of solve
problems by listening to other people
talk a little trick a little bit of
being detached so
yeah that's the extrovert and and I
guess I do as I'm sitting here
reading these definitions I guess I am
more of an introvert the weird thing is
that I talk for a literal living uh so
then we get to the Omniverse thing
the Omniverse thing
is
I'm trying not to read this whole
definition uh
some individuals can be both reserved
and outgoing
they can assume the personality traits
of both an introvert and an extrovert
that person is called an Omniverse all
right and then there's an ambivert
which is
ambiverts are those who score midpoint
on the introvert extrovert scale they
can be introverted or an extrovert
depending on the context or how they
feel at the moment so this is kind of
like just to catch-all I mean come on
bro what are we really doing here we're
gonna say like hey there's these two
things but you can actually be anything
this is kind of weird right that's what
it seems like here yeah yeah especially
that last this just kind of like made me
lose a lot of respect
I thought we had a big topic
unless these other people the Omniverse
and ambivert are like super rare it's
like saying hey a car can be either
black or white or it can be any other
car I think that's what we just did we
could have a big talk about what you
know but these cars are black and these
cars are white and here White's a little
bit cooler black shows up uh you know
more dirt just a little bit of a problem
but it'd be warmer if you're in a cold
climate and so you kind of get in this
discussion about black and white cars
and you're like oh but a car Community
color in the world
so this is kind of what we just got into
here yeah it makes me want to throw this
whole conversation out the window record
a different podcast I don't know it's
kind of well you know like astrology
right where
Oh you mean like Sagittarius yeah that
kind of thing oh yeah zodiac signs and
whatnot and you know how you read your
daily horoscope whatever and it has all
these things and it's kind of the same
deal it's like
um man you're very reserved but but
um but down to express feelings do you
need it you know like you know what I
would be like back in the world when I
was when I was a single dude I'd be out
you know in some some whatever bar
hanging out talking to a girl and you
know the girl will be like what you know
what you know be talking for a while I'm
like man what sign are you this is not
1970 by the way okay this is like the in
the I guess in the 90s a goal will be oh
you know what sign are you gonna be like
oh I'd be like Oh I'm Sagittarius oh I
knew it yeah I knew you were and then I
say oh I'm actually not a Sagittarius I
was kidding oh what are you wearing and
I'd say um Capricorn or is that one yep
I'd be like I'm actually Capricorn oh I
knew it and I would do this to him four
times
it'll be like this stuff is stupid what
you're talking about let's not play this
game you must be on the cusp on the cusp
of that's the thing
oh your your Moon is waning Sagittarius
you're in the you're the ambivert of
Capricorn oh dude so that's kind of what
we're dealing with here a little bit it
feels there's some of those over
undertones whatever of it that I mean
look we know shy people right we know
people that are introverted 100 yeah we
know people that are extroverted 100 and
we know people that are in between this
my point I guess this is just more a
description yeah instead of just trying
to categorize everybody because yeah
because there's also people that are
sort of introverted but they also yeah
whatever yeah I feel like a lot of the
psychology stuff is um I say psychology
I I believe I do believe and it is like
legitimate stuff because it's just like
studying people and personalities and
commonalities and all this stuff so tell
me makes sense so but you're right just
like you're saying like everyone's the
same but everyone's different it's kind
of like yeah like you can categorize
people but you're gonna find nuanced
variation and stuff like that so it's
like okay now we gotta categorize the
Nuance yeah so that's a it feels like I
don't know this is the first time me
reading all this stuff with you so but
that's what it feels like is going on
maybe that's how astrology kind of got
started you see I'm saying where like
they were like oh yeah all these people
were acting way different when they were
born in December then these people were
acting way different because they were
born in May
see what I'm saying then there's like
this is a trash idea yeah I think so too
but hey you know
uh yeah I've got like the definitions of
Omniverse here
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground